all right everybody welcome and thank
you for joining me it is once again a
day that means that we have a White
House coronavirus press briefing my
approach today is going to be a little
bit different to it not because it is
almost Passover but because I just have
some phone calls and that I have to do a
little bit later so we're gonna get to
that momentarily
and I will tell you what the plan is for
today and it's it's just all going to be
amazing you know that's really the
takeaway and we are very close to
defeating the invisible scourge now back
to reality let's look at the numbers as
we have them today
globally we have hit 1.5 million
official cases and we are above 87,000
official deaths yesterday in the United
States we had 33 thousand new cases and
1970 deaths today we have 22,000 new
cases and already 1,600 new deaths and
of course we still have many hours here
and those numbers very well could get
worse updated numbers from the United
States in total four hundred and
twenty-two thousand official cases the
real number is many many more deaths are
about to hit 15,000 either today or
tomorrow a growingly tragic number New
York and New Jersey representing about
200,000 of the four hundred and
twenty-two thousand cases Michigan now
over 20,000 we have three I'm sorry one
two one two three four five six states
between 15 and 20 thousand cases and
then a whole bunch more close to hitting
10,000 thus far updates from the model
interestingly the model was updated
today this is the IHM ii model and it
says we are now four days from the peak
of daily deaths that peak expected to be
not three thousand deaths in a day but
now down to 2,200 so this is an
improvement in a sense in terms of the
total number of deaths we've seen a 27
percent decline
from yesterday to today from about
82,000 yesterday it was 93 thousand the
day before down to 60,000 and of course
of course
any reduction is good any reduction is
good and that is always what we want to
see and we will continue tracking those
numbers on a daily basis and see what
comes of them and we will go from there
welcome to everybody watching on YouTube
remember if you're watching on YouTube
hit that like button and hit the
subscribe button
Joseph din zis says via super chat chaff
Sameach I think you mean hogs amok David
hope you have a great Passover all the
love from a German Jew in Seattle take
care of yourself in these crazy times
been abusing says to me the last episode
of better call Saul felt like Breaking
Bad will bide never provide the same
feeling in relation to Obama I don't
know about that I actually I I believe
Bernie getting out today was the right
decision but I don't know if today was
the right time to me it would have made
a lot more sense three weeks ago or it
would make a lot more sense three or
four weeks from now to me doing it in
the middle of the peak of a global
pandemic the likes of which we've not
seen for a hundred years seems to me
like he's squandering political capital
where if the idea is to make a really
big impact make demands from Biden or
you know whatever I mean like whatever
it is I feel like in 12 hours people are
already gonna not be talking about
Bernie dropping out anymore and my sense
is that having done it three weeks ago
or three weeks from now would have maybe
given him a more effective use of
political capital but what the hell do I
know I'm not running campaigns I'm just
giving you my thoughts here other super
chats Townsend Koch says David Bernie
supporters in NC Florida PA should
definitely vote Biden but what's wrong
with people refusing to run up the score
for Biden in Massachusetts or New York
nothing people everybody should do
whatever they want but if people want to
do that go ahead let's see here Stephen
Kenneth Ben
destiny said Bernie's loss means
progressive politics are unelectable I
don't know I haven't seen it I don't
know people often miss state what people
have said didn't see it can't possibly
react to it
Zach Williams says new member here
thanks for being a great source Thank
You Zach for your support
Adam Waddington says David if you were
given a chance to interview Trump would
you take it yes and what would you ask
him I'd have to think about it I would
need some time to develop questions
Steven Kenneth Pannell says that Kyle
says Bernie should run and I have no
idea what Kyle's saying I certainly
can't take you at your word that that is
what Kyle is saying so I am unable to
react to that I apologize let me say
thanks to will l will L is new member
number one one one one one today at join
pakman.com thanks will I appreciate it
welcome if you were watching on twitch
twitch is a beautiful place to watch the
streams it's a perfect place I would
argue vision outcasts has grabbed the
twitch subscription and T watay has
subscribed with prime very much
appreciate that also welcome to folks
watching on Twitter as well as Facebook
live very very much appreciate it
a few things to go through let me see
here let's see what we've got let's
first check if there's an update on the
time today from Donald Trump Trump says
it will be at 5:30 beautiful that gives
me a little more time with you fine
folks okay here's something as many of
you know we famously coined the term
wanted somebody in this I don't take
credit for it the stream collectively
coined the term data mail as a fight
against beta mail which is like a really
dumb insult from Republicans and we have
had more and more requests for some kind
of date a female shirt now of course the
whole data mail thing is a play on beta
mail so date a female we won't let me
let me back up Seth who developed the
shirt has offered incredibly generously
to do a female version which would be
sort of like a slow
fit what's called the women's fit shirt
I'm just the messenger don't come after
me that's what it's called but Seth
wants to know should it just be this
same graphic except it says female or is
there some other phrase or image or
something that would make more sense for
the women's version of the shirt so let
me know I think the best way would be
maybe email me through my website david
pakman.com use the contact form let me
see if there are any obviously good
suggestions AI female data lady fiscal
female doesn't doesn't really make sense
day to femme oh that's not bad day to
femme would be an interesting one femm e
uh al female not AI female i don't know
what al female even means data babe but
data babe is interesting although i that
could that could maybe be seen as bad or
you know you know i don't want to get in
trouble
scarf lady no no they it's got to be a
data related concept date FM seems to be
getting a lot of people titillated i
guess I would say anyway email me we
will develop that Seth has graciously
graciously offered to donate some
additional design time to doing a
woman's version of the shirt okay here
is Donald Trump yesterday saying we're
going to hold the money to the w-h-o
minutes later he's asked by a reporter
is that a good idea he says I never said
it okay this happens within minutes take
a look
World Health Organization because they
really are they called it wrong they
call it wrong they really they missed
the call they could have called it
months earlier they would have known and
they should have known and they probably
didn't know so we'll be looking into
that very carefully and we're gonna put
a hold on money spent to the w-h-o so he
just said we're gonna put a hold on the
money
put a very powerful hold on it it's very
powerful hold this is minutes later
reporter asks if that's a good idea he
says I never said that now as you all
know you just watched it he of course
didn't say that rather he did say it he
didn't say we're going to look at it he
said we're putting a very powerful hold
on the WH o money and you know did he
forget is he having memory issues is he
just a weaponized liar we don't really
know another very strange moment from
yesterday here's Donald Trump claiming
that Ivanka created 15 million jobs take
a listen to this don't vodka Trump who
just wants to have people working that's
what I gave her lots of options and what
do you like and she created over 15
million jobs working with some of you
but working with the the biggest
companies in the world they were
training and training like nobody has
ever seen but she started off with the
goal of 500,000 jobs and that she's up
to over 15 million ok so again do you
guys think Trump believes that when he
says it I'll give you a few hints number
one the total number of people working
before coronavirus was a hundred and
fifty-eight million that means if Ivanka
created 15 million jobs forget about
whether she did or whether she does
anything if Ivanka created 15 million
jobs that means that Ivanka Trump
created 10 percent 10 percent of all US
jobs furthermore the Trump
administration has created only 6.2
million jobs so how could she possibly
have created 15 million jobs now maybe
she created some of these in other
countries by you know hiring sweatshop
workers in China or something to make
her clothing but that wouldn't be 8
million additional jobs so does Trump
know that this is mathematically
impossible aside from being ludicrous
conceptually or does he not know is he
confused I have no idea you let me know
what what you believe about that a few
other super chats are coming in welcome
by the way if you're joining us Donald
Trump's press conference scheduled for
the bottom of the hour bottom of the
hour let's see here oh and let me get
back over we're keeping an eye on it by
the way if any if any feed goes live in
the room let me know and I will put up
that feed we always prefer to be in the
room rather than out of it I guess I
would say okay super chats are coming in
let's see what is on your mind today mr.
lieutenant pink says thanks for the
company during the lockdown my pleasure
brandy Hamden has grabbed the You Tube
membership RC from the NYC says I think
many states watched what happened with
the indirect voter suppression in
Wisconsin should the Democratic National
Convention be canceled I don't have it I
it's not I'd really don't know I I leave
it to the experts
it seems that holding it as scheduled
and in person right now is not the right
idea but I leave it to the experts to
determine that Ray H LD says do you
think Joe Biden has a chance of beating
Trump yes I do I do J Applegate says can
you tell us what it would take for you
to agree to shave your whole head or
just the top there listen if I shave my
head I'm shaving the whole thing right
I'm not gonna shave just the top and
leave this stuff on the sides that would
be insane I don't know what it would
take let me put it this way I'd know it
if I saw it and I've not seen it so far
let's let's leave it at that for the
time being Michael says why is America
at 400,000 cases and everybody else at
120 thousand or less freedom can't
explain it many countries have more
democracy index than US and some don't
even have 10,000 yeah it's called
incompetent leadership incompetent
leadership and being too slow that's
about it Lee Douglas says please make
the lady shirt available in plus sizes
we'll see we don't have much control
over the the available sizes I will tell
you full rocker says have you heard of
Trump super fanboy anomaly or anomaly I
have not Mikayla McGonagall says lost my
grin
mother to the virus today I am so sorry
to hear that Michaela my condolences
please please stay home sleep well and
in peace my sweet grandmas so so tragic
every day someone on my stream has lost
somebody every single day it is very
real and tragic and I'm I'm so sorry to
hear that
Michaela really really sorry we are
standing by for Donald Trump and the
White House coronavirus press briefing
so a minute today we're handling it a
little bit differently yesterday I did
the Trump part and then I had to go
today we're doing something else I have
three different calls I have to make
today so I'll be with you until Trump
starts when Trump starts I'm going to
step away the stream will keep going
nobody's got to get scared it's gonna be
fine I'm gonna step away and do these
phone calls and then I will be back for
when medical experts speak and for when
the questions start okay so that's the
that's the plan for that's the plan for
today
Thomas W says 2020 battle of the
septuagenarian yogurt brains
inconsolable says a bizarre and absurd
narrative that's gaining traction in
your subreddit is the idea that Trump is
going to institute Medicare for all in
response to Kevin as some people call it
making him a better choice than Biden
can you please debunk there is zero
chance in hell that Donald Trump does
that and it's just ridiculous John Larry
says how about data chick I I don't know
if people like that idea for we're
looking for a female alternative to the
data male t-shirt which our friend seth
has agreed to design I don't know if
data chick is the is the way to go but
I'll keep taking suggestions ninja
Tribble says I've heard Sam cedar said
that Kyle told him destiny thinks you
are secretly an alpha male can you
please comment no I cannot thanks ninja
Steven Kenneth says should Bernie run in
2020 for you didn't answer the question
very annoying
no she he should he should not he's
going to be like 82 at
point right you know he shouldn't that's
it he shouldn't run also why did you
block various channels of mine I have
never lied or done anything wrong what
are your thoughts I don't know you'd
have to ask I think our moderators
banned you or I don't know I these these
things are these are not paramount
issues of importance right now Matt
Chavez says Rogen has a video up
explaining Trump / Biden yes
will address tomorrow Christopher Korea
says Rogen gave you a shout-out on
today's podcast I didn't see that I
would love if anybody has let's check
that out together if somebody I saw he
interviewed Lex Friedman today if
somebody can give me the time code of
the Rogen shout out today I will I will
put it up on the screen it at this point
I don't think it's a secret that I'm
scheduled to be on with Joe soon and I
just don't know if it's gonna happen
because of you know the virus quite
frankly but I would love to I have not
seen today's episode yet so if somebody
can give me a time code then I would
love it and we can look at it together
in real time sure raka Barry says I was
Wisconsin poll worker didn't show up
because none of the workers were tested
probably smart probably smart
Payton Pelin says you could rock a
proper undercut just saying I don't know
what that is I don't know what an
undercut is to be perfectly frank of
course if I do a podcast with Rogan soon
I would talk about his view on the Trump
Biden thing of course of course of
course I would there is no doubt about
it okay let's see here does anybody know
if there is any stream that is in the
room live right now I would gladly
switch to that so we can see sort of the
process as it's going and if somebody
can get me the time code for the Rogan
shout out today I would gladly look at
both of those but I am not seeing either
so far Washington Post doesn't seem to
have anything happening live in the room
right now people talking about
tulsi still yeah I don't know I don't
know anything about tulsi
at this point Washington Post is not
live in the room okay maybe nobody is
live in the room right now maybe that's
it no all right well listen if anybody
goes live please let me know wait maybe
time is live let's take a look here now
I'm just not seeing it okay anyway keep
me posted
keep me posted and we will do all we
will do everything that we need to do
all right very very good and get me yes
I see people saying where is the Rogen
video if someone gives me that I can't I
think he did three hours today with Lex
Friedman I can't do three hours of
looking through it but if someone tells
me we're in today's Rogan podcast he
mentions me we will go to the shoutout
and we will do it very very quickly and
we will do it very very strongly okay
here's something fun all right let's
just take a brief break from bad things
yesterday I agreed to take a proper
hairbrush and just see how my hair would
react to it and I did it yesterday and
producer Noah has isolated some of the
most compelling moments of me doing that
and what I'm going to do is I'm gonna
paste a link in twitch and YouTube right
now to a series of gifts okay please
turn these into memes and and send them
to me okay we are gonna be promoting we
want to do something fun we'll be
promoting these all over the place turn
these into things edit them do you know
whatever people who know what to do with
them can do here's another one and some
of these are really really compelling my
hair reacting in very strange ways to
what I did yesterday this was the comb
forward as you can see here I started
going forward really aggressively and it
got kind of weird here I went into the
full kind of like Beatles look and it
became really difficult to host the
stream when this one was going on then I
kind of shook it out and it became kind
of Bieber like in a strange way so all
of these images
all of these animated images are
available to you I just pasted the link
a bunch of times there's that and then I
went back back I felt good it just was
really good to get all the hair out of
my face it went back and that was
beautiful and then we kept going back I
puffed up the sides a little bit and
then I kind of did a forward really just
kind of smacking at my hair forward a
little bit that worked and then this was
a really weird emo moment from this was
the most emo moment from yesterday's
stream as you can see and that got
really really weird so one more time I'm
pasting links on twitch and YouTube to
all of these animated images I have a
lot of confidence that people are going
to come up with some really really
creative stuff for us that then they are
going to send to me if you're just
joining us we will be we are just about
a half hour from the start of theory
today's coronavirus task force press
briefing it was originally scheduled for
5:00 and it has been rescheduled for the
bottom of the hour according to Donald
Trump's Twitter chat we do have racism
very very aggressive racism happening in
twitch chat so we are banning people I'm
just dropping the ban hammer very
aggressively and people are being
brutalized by the banhammer right now
moderators remember we do not allow that
kind of over racism and being coy about
misspelling the n-word is not gonna fly
my friends it's not going to fly let me
say thank you to Ben Hochberg Ben
Hochberg is new member number two today
at join pakman.com very much appreciate
that
super chats continue to come in let's
see here uh Nick Piper says what's with
all the epoch times ads do they think
targeting your audience is good
marketing I don't know yeah a lot of
people tell me that they are running a
lot of ads on my channel it sounds like
a waste of money to me I don't know
Bolkiah writer says I love Bernie but
hate his supporters david adams says
what about data Queen as an alternative
the date of male t-shirt date a queen is
an idea that's not a bad idea
I could I could see going for that Diana
Bridget says just renewed membership
I vote for data lady data lady is not a
bad one either I'm just making a note of
some of these different ideas that
people are mentioning very good Boyle RB
says Jimmy Neutron hair nice thank you
yeah it's it's getting pretty bad I'm
not gonna lie but I'm doing what I can
oh it does look like Fox News is in the
room so maybe I'll switch over to that
momentarily that is a little risky
though you know Fox News at any at any
time might look at dropping a ban hammer
on me which we definitely don't want
Anna Burgos says 2848 okay let's do the
Rogen thing
Lex Friedman Joe Rogan April 8th let's
see I believe this is today all right
let's look at this together I've not
seen this before I am told that Joe
Rogan mentions me today at 2848 let's
see what happens here no first of all
folks I'm barely paying attention okay
if you're getting your political advice
from me I'm a okay I am a comedian
slash Cagefighting commentator you know
how you have friends that don't know
much about fighting and they'll say
something like I think Bruce Lee could
kick John Jones ass yeah that's me with
politics okay don't listen to me for
political advice you want to listen to
people what for political advice listen
to people that are actually paying
attention listen to guys who that's
their living guys like Kyle kolinsky
listen to jimmy dore he does a fantastic
job breaking down politics he
understands it right listen to the
people that wrote the hill watch that
show it's fantastic it's on youtube
there's a lot of people David Pakman he
understands Paulo
but what I am saying is I don't want to
vote for someone that has a mental
problem
okay well listen Joe and I are scheduled
to have a chat soon
I don't know if and when it'll happen
but I will talk to him about all of this
Biden stuff we're gonna - I am sure Joe
then will allow me to discuss that in a
lot of detail with him and I look
forward to I look forward to doing that
Paul JM says the data male t-shirt is
pretty phallic is it really this this
doesn't seem phallic to me is data
phallic is a graph phallic now that I
don't know that i buy that guys I'm not
sure I'm on that on that train philip
angst says hello David love your show
what is going on in Nevada or Nevada
let's see is there where is that where
is Nevada Nevada Nevada 129 cases I
don't know what is going on there
2200 I'm not is there has that number
changed let me see oh my goodness
Oh oh wow it in like an hour
22,000 new cases in a single day that is
incredible Wow I was supposed to go to
Vegas in two weeks I'm glad that
conference got canceled that is
absolutely insane I don't know the
backstory there I have no idea if
anybody knows what's going on in Nevada
with the numbers by all means let me
know but that is stunning 22,000 cases
in a single day in Nevada still very few
deaths presumably because these are
relatively new cases which have not I
guess like kind of the politically
correct term is to say these are not
cases that have resolved yet but that is
shocking shocking shocking number out of
out of Nevada crazy
Brian Somerville sends a super chat
Bolkiah writer says never Biden people
would rather throw marginalized people
under the bus instead of voting for Joe
and protesting his administration from
day one Danny Bowman is a SOI boy now
Matt's like Matt's will endure says do
you think Bernie fans will vote for
Trump again a fraction of them will I'm
gonna have a big piece about that
tomorrow so let me not preempt my own
commentary but I'm gonna be I mean
be talking about about that tomorrow on
the program okay I'm going to do my one
pitch the last three streams I have
attempted to only do one attempt to sell
you on membership and it has gone better
than ever so the the better it does the
less I will mention it okay so I'm gonna
mention this one time now okay
we're mostly funded by memberships so
there's YouTube super chat YouTube ad
revenue twitch subscriptions all this
stuff the companies take a big slice
every time we get a dollar through those
platforms YouTube twitch everybody takes
a big slice okay that's why we have our
own system at join pakman.com when you
sign up there we pay two point nine
percent to swipe credit cards and we
keep the rest
ninety seven point one percent okay
because of the virus we're all in it
together we're all struggling together
in march
three hundred and eighty nine of our
website members canceled their
memberships we've never had that many
people cancel in one month before i
don't blame a single person for it i get
what's going on unemployment is
exploding we all get it all right
three hundred and eighty nine people
cancelled YouTube revenue down thirty
five percent so my ask is I don't want
your last dollar
I don't want your last two dollars if
you are in the umbrella of people that
can afford two bucks a month consider
grabbing a subscription at join
pakman.com we've got a goal of twenty
five website members during some of
these streams we've gotten fifty even
close to seventy five people signing up
sometimes if you apply the coupon code
twenty twenty now you will save sixty
six percent you don't have to take the
coupon if you can pay full price do it
we had somebody yesterday get a five
hundred dollar membership during the
stream it was amazingly generous but if
you can afford just two bucks a month
that coupon code will make your
membership two bucks a month or twenty
for the year which is like a dollar
eighty three a month okay
that's my ask everybody who signs up I
will thank you are all amazing people
whether or not you sign up the streams
are for everybody it's not just for paid
subscribers but that that is my one ask
and I will make sure that everybody who
signs up today during the stream gets a
very very sincere and beautiful thank
you okay
twitch messages that I want to read
buhdeuce I Dido has subscribed on Twitch
and says keep up the good work mr.
Pakman thank you Rocko's Modern Life has
subscribed on Twitch and says love the
show David very powerful two month
Prime subscription yes and thank you
Saoirse score Asst has gifted 5
subscriptions on Twitch goku has
subscribed for three months and
beryllium poisoning has subscribed with
prime thanks to all of you thanks to all
of you I very much appreciate that okay
Josh Allen has subscribed on YouTube
Danny Thompson says t-shirt idea David
Pakman fan club with your DP logo I'd
get one right away
also do like and subscribe the stream
and like on every one of your YouTube
and Facebook videos I do thanks Danny
I really do appreciate that very much
appreciate your support
Christopher Correa says Joe Rogan oh the
timestamp
thank you we already did get to that
appreciate it Daniel Rivera says is it
easier or harder for Trump to win this
time I think it's a huge question mark
because of the X Factor that is
coronavirus I think we have no idea how
November is going to shake out yet yet
we may be in the midst of the second
wave of the virus the economy may have
heavily recovered it may not have I
think we just don't know yet it's too
early to say Helen Alderson says how
about facts and figures with a
silhouette you know that's an
interesting idea we're looking for like
a female version of the data male shirt
what Helen is suggesting is facts and
figures with the female silhouette I
think that that is very interesting but
I worry that it could be seen as
misogynistic and it could get us in some
trouble I mean it's unfortunate that I
have to even
thinking in those terms but I think it's
possible that it could get us into some
trouble and so you know it's a question
mark but it's a very creative idea very
creative idea
Adam fresh design says why not just date
a girl yeah that that's a possibility
for sure
Lauren Tweeddale ascends a super super
chat Daniel Ryan suggests dated Eva
sorry where'd that go
dated Eva lot la loire n't we Dale says
how about data female with the F and E
as data points okay Seth I hope Seth is
on the stream and taking notes about all
of these different ideas that folks are
helping us to uh to workshop I Mir sends
a becomes a YouTube member Joshua hasty
says David released the children of the
live shirt oh that's another shirt idea
okay another shirt idea would be Jesse
Lee Peterson this black conservative who
has interviewed me before he calls
people on the left I guess children of
the lie it would be cool to do a t-shirt
called children of the lie with
caricatures of me Stephen Kenneth
destiny bunnell ii sam cedar and anthony
mellon Fantan oh i think that that would
be really good and that would be another
t-shirt possibility matter no just just
something to think about another another
possibility okay
uh-oh and just speaking of which let me
see if I can find Jesse Lee Peterson
just because we have time David Pakman
let me see if I can find this hilarious
song that was done uh okay oh okay here
it is so check this out
this is like some of the backstory on
all of this data data mail stuff just so
people get a sound
[Applause]
[Music]
it's so amazing
you like black I'm sorry you like let's
slap you ever slept with a slap would
you date a slag question that's the
answer but I don't like the answer you
don't understand the question I think I
understand it what is it about the
question that difficult for you is it
are these really the most important
topics for you afternoon
okay I mess it so all the thing you're
dumb okay I want to stuff it Paul
you do know what you won't say amazing
oh do you know what anyway okay I think
people kind of get the gist for what
we're dealing with with Jesse Lee
Peterson so that obviously that is not
as it really happened that's an edit
that's an edit meant meant to be meant
to be comical let me put it that way
okay let me say a few new member
thank-yous before things get completely
out of control
Chris Lempa is new member number three
today at join pakman.com Ryan Revis is
new member number four at join
pakman.com min cheol Zhang is new member
number five today at join pakman.com
thanks men also want to say thank you to
Meredith Meredith helped cop I hope I'm
pronouncing that correctly apologies in
advance
Sean Wolfe finger is new member number
seven today Jared bish is new member
number eight today thanks Jared Kurt
string
field is new member number nine John
Barr schinsky or bars in ski is new
member number ten today
Reggie Cooper is new member number
eleven Nazli Malik is new member number
twelve
Marshall Simmons is new member number
thirteen today I want to say thanks to
joshua pope who is new member number
fourteen christopher vigil is new member
number fifteen thanks Christopher Adams
is new member number sixteen a
Stewart Robertson is new member number
seventeen and Dorian s-sir is new member
number eighteen today I will make sure
everybody gets a thank you everybody
gets a thank you as always very very
important stuff okay other super chats
coming in a thanks to David fields and
music man for the subscriptions
incredible TV says smash that like
button people yes if you were watching
on youtube remember hit the like button
and hit the subscribe button and I
suggest a big wind-up when you when you
do that you got to do the big windup on
like and subscribe very very useful
Bob regio has subscribed at the SOI boy
level as has Ryan McWeeny William
Vollrath says just because Mike Murphy
has subscribed Anna Burgos says what's
the name of the clip that you mentioned
your thoughts on New York City after Co
vid and people leaving the congestion
and fears of the second wave you know
I'm not sure Anna I don't know and I
don't even know if it was on the
broadcast show or the bonus show I
apologize I have a hard time myself
finding some of my old clips
thanks to Rob copy and Joseph Anderson
as well as banne parlous and Chuck we
Pitchford bazzill van de says watching
for about six months thanks for all your
work
Thank You fazil Ronnie Silva sends a
super chat whoa where'd that go ray
Rivera says great job Dave amost oh
little yes we watch you every day that's
translation from Spanish my friends
Vickey chance has signed up I Muir says
factual female you know that's an
interesting one that's an interesting
one it could be the same image as this
but it could say factual female that
that might work that actually might work
and it wouldn't offend anybody never
want to offend anybody with our gear
here's our favorite bloomberg reporter
entering the room always good to see him
skunk game says David I think Nevada is
an anomaly total cases more than total
tests is that an error yeah I really
have no idea we just noticed that let's
refresh and see if it's still there and
it's gone I think it was just a mistake
for a few minutes there were 22,000 new
cases in Nevada today and now it's back
down to 376 it didn't make sense it
didn't pass the sniff test and it seems
it appears at least that it was just a
glitch at least that's what it seems
like right now whoa okay Christine says
do you trust our votes will even be
counted honestly this administration is
so powerful and corrupt I'm losing faith
that it isn't all for nothing I have
also lost some faith that our votes will
be counted and I think vote-by-mail
you know Trump says vote-by-mail is bad
and corrupt I think vote-by-mail is good
and we should do it for a number of
different reasons which I outline in a
clip today that we'll be publishing a
little bit later a little bit later let
me say a few twitch thank-yous let's see
here
squid pro yo has subscribed with prime
Incubus and he kudos as well as Savar
--ga have all subscribed on Twitch
janabul has subscribed Daniel 84 has
subscribed
Reggie nerd and robot eyes have
subscribed so has Jeff 1014 black Mikey
Dre Noah Shane with the message pandemic
rights morbus mi a cat
see and hot Steve have all subscribed at
twitch.tv slash David Pakman okay let me
do a few other thank-yous I don't want
to fall too far behind on website
membership thank yous I already thanked
durian so let me now say thanks to Jason
Seaton Jason Seaton is new member number
Magnus Beaton is new member number 20
Emily Ilsan thanks Emily new member
number 21 charlie car is new member
number 22 today Margaret Williams coming
in at number 23
Parker Cruz --all I hope I didn't push
the butcher that is new member number 24
Jonathan Overby is new runt new member
number 25
let's go for 50 and number 26 is Zeno
Paz Costa Zeno Paz Costa is number 26
today's press briefing has been
rescheduled for the bottom of the hour
we are just moments from that time we
have the microphone holder for press
questions in the room that's a sign
we're probably getting closer to the
start we are live on Twitter twitch
facebook and youtube just as a reminder
I have a couple conference calls in a
bit so when Trump starts I'm gonna go
black I'm gonna black out my video I'm
gonna have a couple phone calls I will
be back for when the doctors speak and
when there are questions yesterday we
reversed it and today I will be back for
the nasty questions and for the
reporters who should be ashamed of
themselves and for actual doctors who
are going to be speaking to us Waller is
me suggests femme de Cal that's an
interesting idea
Ashton graves says what book has most
influenced your political views you know
I really couldn't say I I don't read
that much the only real political books
I read are like theory I don't read any
of like the you know this politician
like I don't read the Obama memoir I
don't read books by pundits I tend to
read economic
theory history and I couldn't really
name one book that has been been you
know particularly large influence vape
Rex has grabbed a beta level YouTube
subscription Wesley Griffin says the
lack of response by the Trump
administration to Corona should have
been the nail in the coffin for
re-election in my humble opinion it
should have been and it may not be and
that's what's so so scary about it
Christine says David I watched the Jesse
Peterson interview the other day I
appreciate your Pro Chand I believe you
were masterful and handling it you are
right
future students will study it let me see
if I can actually find that moment that
was like an indirect dig at Jesse Lee
Peterson and I don't know that he got it
Jesse Lee Peterson David Pakman wanna
stay here here it is I can find that
easily because it's right at the end
let's take a look okay a lot of people
have been waiting for this one let me go
right right to the end here let's take a
listen okay she's trying to take the
shame out of being called a and
women and so we videotaped that and that
is coming out next Thursday is so
amazing the they feel amazing
incredible you like I'm sorry you
like let's I don't know any have you
ever slept with a I don't think so
would you date us led to purge order
it's not a term I use amazing my final
question oh do you know what a is
when you see one no make sure you watch
this let Wacha on the father thing thank
you my final question did you have fun
no no listen I think that this is in in
a thousand years when the sociologists
and the Philosopher's try to figure out
what exactly happened in the United
States are right around this time this
type of conversation is going to be
incredibly informative for them so I'm
glad to have participated in it good man
I think only thing Wow jesse was amazing
and the installation guy nice you're a
nice guy
thank you for coming man thank you for
having me I really do appreciate thank
you all right and so anyway yeah I think
it's sort of like went over his head or
maybe he just pretended I mean he's not
you know sometimes he I don't think he's
playing a character but that is the real
Jessie like behind the scenes that was
the same Jessie so I don't know maybe it
didn't go over his head maybe it did I
really I don't really know but in any
case that was that that was my
appearance with uh with Jesse Lee
Peterson and if I'm back in LA I would
love to do it again it would be really a
pleasure okay let me say thank you to
some really special people Benny oh and
Mishka burger that is a family name of
mine burger BER ger yes you guys are new
members at join pakman.com Jon bak
Tolley now I could I think I've
recognized that name I think John maybe
was a member at one point already is new
member number 28 Janelle
Manning is new member number 29 Holden
Vito is new member number 30 today
Richard B Lewis B I'm guessing it's like
that guy Howard case Stern who uses the
middle initial to distinguish himself
from Howard Stern Richard B Lewis is
number 31 not the comedian Richard Lewis
Jim welniak is number 32 today
Keenan Miller Keenan is new member
number 33 beautiful Gareth
Owen is new member number 34 David
Sanborn is new member number 35 and
Rhonda fee andhaka is new member number
36 today Rhonda thank you thank you very
much appreciate it we should be just
minutes from the start of today's press
conference I will be stepping away what
momentarily when it starts because I
have a few phone calls while Trump
speaks well that guy was wearing like a
full face mask wow that's really
covering everything then I will be back
for doctor's comments and questions in a
little bit colleague and crafts has
grabbed a membership pair Taryn says you
look like a manga character with the
hair wild yeah I guess so
I don't know I might I might do a
haircut sue and myself we'll see I don't
know it's starting to become a
distraction quite frankly and so I may
need to do something just to you know
calm everybody down
waffles derp Awful's said JLP said it
date a would you date a oh
that's interesting
interesting John Kelly has signed up on
YouTube heard about it says do you know
why the Nevada case count skyrocketed it
was a glitch it's been fixed we fixed
the glitch to quote office space the
movie choc we Pitchford says youngest
candidate for office in southwest
michigan doing great and will win the
primary thank you for being an
inspiration ok I'm not I'm not aware of
this thank you beetle Greg says David
what's your favorite song I don't have
one favorite song how could I possibly
pick one favorite song Mike says the
hair is as glorious as always keep this
look
Alvaro bazan says my mate who voted for
Trump was going to vote Bernie how
crucial are the supreme court seats we
may lose for our progressive movement if
45 is reelected huge huge Biden getting
to choose a Supreme Court justice
instead of Trump will have an impact for
decades on the very fabric of our
country you might not care but there is
no denying that that is the reality let
me say thanks to cheerio she for the
support over on Twitch I appreciate that
we seem to be very close very close to
the start of today's press conference
Gillian Kobe says Kenneth Stephen
destiny bonel ii got combed in this
debate the bonus meme pooh pooh
pet they laugh yeah I don't I don't
really know anything about that there is
a really funny oh there's like a
compilation of my how would I even find
this
let me see david pakman Twitch meme
compilation there's such a funny video
someone made
I can't find it if someone can tell me
how to find this like two minute
compilation somebody made of me like
pretending not to know any of the
references in online culture which is
all a joke by the way these are all
exaggerations that I'm doing just to
have fun
damn I wish I knew how to find it
Oh supposedly fun is trying to send it
but links are blocked if someone can
describe how to find it that would be
better yeah I don't know how to find
that people are sending the link but
that's blocked the most likable boomer
on Twitch that's it the most likeable
boomer on Twitch ah there it is
beautiful okay check this out this was
this was really pretty expertly done
take a look at this and I actually have
made an account and I am going to do a
premier stream on Twitch sometime soon
let me say thanks to some folks signing
up with twitch prime Young Mattu
punished mouton have I turned down the
four wot settings in OBS to get rid of
the stream delay dear God ah no I
haven't and I will be raiding pokey main
when I am done because she follows me on
Twitter thank you - see this is where
twitch is very different than YouTube on
YouTube it's like I'm getting super
chats from Kevin I'm getting one from
Nolan on Twitch I just had someone
called I spank my monkey every night
subscribe with twitch crimes right by
popular demand our god rating
your stream when I'm done with mine over
the top of the hour peace and love to
quote the great Ringo Starr the
Kardashians are lying to you I don't
even know what they're saying somebody
can explain to me exactly what I would
do on here please tell me but I don't
let me just listen to a little bit of
what's going on I don't even get what
this is I rarely have five thousand
viewers with whom I could raid anybody
now I wanted I've been angling to at
some point be raided by pokey main and I
actually may have the goods this evening
I guess not people apparently doesn't
extract incredibly offensive comment to
make I don't know who hiker Pepe laughs
okay so I can tell me what manga asks me
it's like what about Earth does that
mean I have no clue what people are
talking about I hope it's not something
horribly racist
thank you so much I follow all right
anyway I think you guys get the idea so
I really appreciate people who put that
they put that together that takes a lot
of scouring and you know looking at a
lot of different elements of my streams
and stuff like that so very very very
much appreciated okay a few other
thank-yous I want to thank Donna Looney
who is new member number 37 join
pakman.com Timothy Stone is new member
number 38 Devon Ortega is new member
number 39 today James fiber is new
member number 40 and Andy Wilcox new
member number 41 41 at join pakman.com
Anthony thank you my friend Andy Andy
not Anthony thank you so much my friend
very much appreciate the support oh okay
I guess people won't just want to see
the last few seconds of this that's fine
her heart rate going up while she says
this anybody noticed that when she
started talking about me she was at 73
and by the end of this her pulse is
elevated is that a goof or is that for
real is anybody else noticing that
ladies and gentlemen welcoming aboard
the show one of the most sought-after
gasps mr. David Pakman what's my take on
John zurka getting 500,000 views
overnight yeah I have no clue what this
is and it doesn't sound super
interesting mentioning me literally
elevated her pulse about 15% that's
interesting
mind you I am now going to be streaming
under the handle David Kenneth destiny
but no second
[Music]
man that is dis legendary right so that
is truly truly stunning and what what an
event I did win the Raja Royale I won I
defeated a gentleman named airsoft fatty
who is I believe so I mean I'm actually
gonna be serious about this okay I'm not
kidding about this I was unfamiliar with
airsoft fatty before I appeared on that
program I believe now airsoft fatty is
one of the premier foremost entertainers
of our time and I encourage everybody to
check out this gentleman's chat channel
it is truly comedic gene I mean it's
really comedic genius and truly one of
the top I would argue maybe the
Entertainer of the decade potentially
airsoft okay Robert
Archer says something something
hairstyle love you David
yes Corey has become a SOI boy mascot
says do you think the public at large
has given up on using politics seems
like a small percent or listening at all
I would say the opposite our YouTube
channel and Facebook page have been
going logarithmic during the last six
weeks now it could be just because
people are home but there is every
indication people are very much engaged
very very much engaged with they with
with politics and news at this point in
time costal Iliescu says thank you for
all of your work please check out
dysfunctional Mary Ock 308 album free on
YouTube best Quarantine album on the
planet okay I will take that under
advisement Lisa Kline war it says just a
little something in the pot again to say
thank you for doing this it would be
torture to get through these without you
thanks Lisa
Micah Gelfand Oh Micah hug Samia if I am
NOT being presumptuous Biden has only
eight allegations of harassment versus
Trump's twenty I'm glad to have the
choice of two creeps to vote for thanks
the NCMA and MSNBC Samantha Sabatino
says I'm here for the nasty questions
you
me both Samantha Chris M you might be
interested in the book architecture
architecture of a techno democracy
investigates using blockchain tech to
enable a more democratic a more fair
democratic process interesting
Donna William says wear a hat thank you
for your hard work appreciate you you
know I'm not really a hat guy actually
you only have I think I have a hat right
here type of hat that I really have and
I don't know that this would really help
I know this is a risk putting this thing
on what do we think actually this is
like Tim Poole's beanie in a way I'm
like Tim Poole now this is kind of
interesting
anyway this is the only sort of thing I
could really do but man it's just it's
almost uncomfortable with all of my hair
underneath it let me see if I can fix it
this is cool right this is like emo
Pakman or something like that
I'm in the band Simple Plan guys check
me out or I'm a conspiracy theorist yeah
I don't know I don't really know it's
weird I don't know how people wear this
stuff it's to a yeah this isn't good
it's not good I think if anything I
would wear like a Red Sox hat or
something like that
hold on now the other thing is I could
also just extend that's this is the only
other possibility but it's weird it's
actually it's a little bit phallic I
don't think it's appropriate there are
children on the stream I'm not gonna do
it okay
the other possibility by the way would
just be wearing a scarf the entire
stream maybe I'll do that yeah this is
actually I think better for me okay
let's continue here let's say a few
other thank-yous I want to say thanks to
no there's nobody else to say thank you
to oh my goodness alright I won't thank
anybody I won't thank anybody okay
John Espinoza says a little something
for the coffee can or Oh what am i doing
we're still waiting for you here we go
a little something for the coffee can or
petty cash fund over at the David Pakman
show thanks for all you do
David Bryson Barnard says my dad thinks
you have Trump derangement syndrome what
are your thoughts
Trump derangement syndrome is a phrase
used to shield Donald Trump from
criticism and essentially to just attack
people and I don't even engage any on
Twitter if somebody sends me a tweet
with Trump derangement syndrome I
instantly mute them I don't think
they're worth engaging with Andrew
Morgan says just JPL is a slot for old
right-wing money okay mouna je Kobus
says welcome oh is a new soy boy jack
says any thoughts on Bernie supporters
jumping ship to trump over mental
degradation concerns when Trump
obviously has mental decline already
yeah I do have thoughts about that and
I'll probably include that tomorrow in
my segment about Bernie Amadou Isaac
says dated aim that's an idea the female
version of the data male shirt could be
dated aim that's not bad that's not bad
at all I think that there's definitely
something there Keaton Klepper says Dave
can you handle the triplets in good
times bad times the Led Zeppelin song I
can I apps if I have the right drum
pedal because which I prefer a DW I
don't remember if I have a 5,000 series
over 7,000 with the right pedal and the
right pedal tuning I can absolutely
handle the triplets in good times bad
times
Amy Ashworth says date alas stand up and
fight back sends a super chat giant
robat says hi David my girlfriend is a
socialist gender critical feminist I
call her surf-and-turf
that's pretty good that's pretty good
Micah Gelfand
says thanks for the work you do and
helping us keep sane during these crazy
times take care and stay safe everyone
millennial cooking dinner says you look
Canadian now thank you
Ron says do you assuming it's a
compliment do you think it's the DNC and
mainstream media's fault that Bernie
lost the primary no I don't know I don't
Berni lost the primary brutally it's
like a two and a half million vote
deficit between him and Joe Biden and to
that's a very simplistic argument that
will lead to progressives never winning
and so I'm not gonna make that argument
I think it's a bad one Jesus Christ asks
have you ever watched a video or stream
of vouch on youtube if yes any thoughts
on him I haven't I haven't and I don't
know what kind of content vouch makes
but if it's political stuff you know it
was weird yesterday people asked me if I
know a bad enchilada and I was like no I
don't know
bad enchilada or empanada empanada and
then someone went on my subreddit and
said you know David why are you
pretending that you don't know who they
are and it's like I have no clue who
they are I I don't watch any political
stuff and there's a whole conversation
happening on my subreddit which I bailed
out at like I don't engage
back-and-forth I just went in and said
why would I deny knowing who someone is
I don't watch any political stuff they
people later told me they did a video
about you dozens of videos show up
constantly of people doing critiques of
what I just I can't respond to them I
don't have time it's like I'm doing
three hours of prep two hours of filming
phone calls doing live streams it's like
I just I just don't watch political
stuff when I'm done I'm watching other
stuff I'm watching chess videos I'm
watching you know live concerts and
whatever but but that has nothing to do
with vouch but if vouch is political you
know in fact when I browse YouTube
personally it's getting a little warm
I'm gonna take the scarf off when I
browse YouTube personally I use a
different account than like the show
channel account and because I never
watch political stuff I am never
recommended political stuff
I'm recommended things that match you
know my search interests so I just am
NOT even coming across a lot of this
material Marco says love your channel
keep it up
proud of you thanks Marco appreciate it
ello says thank you for thinking through
the issues logically
thank you for supporting the show Andrew
Morgan says I mean JPL is a slot for old
Republican money
what's JPL do you mean JLP Jesse Lee
Petersen Timothy says data wombat
Garrett Campbell says David do you
listen to animals as leaders I don't if
not you must check them out especially
Matt Garcia's drumming unreal I will do
that I will do that thanks to Philip
Neyman and Claudia Cornejo who have
grabbed YouTube memberships very very
much appreciate that I want to say a
very special thank you to Tonya nulled
who is new member number 42 42 today at
join pakman.com look at that my friends
look at that go 50 of course being the
goal
DJ chaos says meinl are the best symbols
Minow makes good stuff I am a big fan of
I have like an old Zildjian dry ride and
it's fantastic absolutely fantastic I
also like Sabian cymbals Matthew Vicente
Z says put the beanie back on paranoid
android 28:23 on Rogen bad empanada is
great his critique of you was about how
wrong you were on Bolivia Jesus it feels
I was Bolivia like eight months ago
George Bush says vouch or the OSH the
OSH definitely someone worth having on
the show all right maybe I'll have we
the team will research the team will
research and it will be an amazing
amazing thing okay let's get an update
about hope people are asking where the
hair gifts are I'll be here there I'll
paste the link in the chat again I'm
pasting it right now on Twitch and then
pasting it right now on YouTube we've
got a bunch of these gifts from
yesterday's stream which
I am I'm inviting you to uh turn into
memes you know do photoshopping whatever
people want to do I think that there's a
lot of material there potentially that
that could be worked on if you're just
joining us on YouTube I have a
teeny-tiny request for you please hit
the like button and hit the subscribe
button these are small small requests
they're free they really help our stream
very very much so make sure that you
like and subscribe
Moy lrb says how can progressive push
policies on Biden now well I actually
think it would have been better for
Bernie Sanders to either have gotten out
three weeks ago or three weeks from now
I think Bernie gets the least spendable
political capital by getting out
literally two days from the peak of a
global a global hundred year pandemic so
I would have liked to see the timing of
it be either earlier or later and that
might have better positioned Bernie to
get some kind of immediate concessions
or something from Joseph R Biden Jr I
don't know that we're gonna get much
anytime soon dr. foul he is here Mike
Pompeo is here dr. BRICS is here dr.
Redfield is here from the CDC and we
will soon see Donald Trump just a
reminder I'm stepping away to some phone
calls as soon as they get started I will
just be blacked out and then I'll come
back in time for the doctor's hopefully
speaking and for nasty questions from
reporters but I will be stepping away
just momentarily let me say thank you to
Ana Burgos who is new member number 43
today at join pakman.com thanks Anna
very much appreciate it Phillip angst
points out that Nevada has been
corrected yes it has incorrectly it was
announced that Nevada had 22,000 new
cases today they don't they don't and
that has been corrected Tiger Ian says
vash talks about rhetoric and optics on
the left
okay is Pompeo being pulled out
is he being pulled off the stage Pompeyo
sort of slowly going over to the door i
guess he was told to stand there is that
Pompeo I believe it is yeah something
weirds going on here guys I'm not gonna
lie there's just a like a weird vibe
behind today's briefing and there is
Donald Trump followed by Mike Pence dr.
Burks standing a lot of other people not
standing which is interesting now dr.
Redfield standing thank you this is a
Holy Week when religious believers of
course the nation will observe Passover
a Good Friday and Easter millions of
Jewish families begin Passover at
sundown tonight a sacred unbroken
tradition that traces back to the
ancient land of Egypt and on Sunday we
celebrate our beautiful wonderful Easter
which we all look forward to kal be back
with you guys man we're going to have
many Easter's together in churches in
the future we're getting closer you see
the numbers we're getting much closer to
getting our country back to the way it
was we have now an extra two countries
that have been attacked 184 they're
being attacked as we speak but we'll all
win some point we're going to all win
we're going to do it sooner than people
think
earlier today I spoke with 10,000 of
America's faith leaders to thank them
for raising the spirits of our people
during these very difficult days well we
may be physically apart we can use this
time to pray to reflect and to focus on
our personal relationship with God I
also spoke with more than 3000 mayor's
County Commissioners and state and
tribal leaders to provide an update on
our administration's ongoing drive to
beat the virus to crush the virus and
that's happening it's happening
I think if you look a little bit more
quickly than people thought maybe a lot
more quickly I hope and it's something
that all over the world we're watching
but people are watching us and seeing
what we're doing and they're very
impressed we're dealing with many
countries right now many many countries
and we're giving them whatever
information we were able to glean I just
spoke with the representatives of the UK
and I think that they're great Prime
Minister is doing much better today or
at least better but certainly he's had a
tough bout and he's still going through
a tough time but he seems to be doing
better and that's good and we we send
our regards to Boris and his family and
his friends all of the people that
really love him he's become a very
popular before this happened became a
very popular prime minister he's doing
an excellent job he loves their country
he loves our country so we appreciate
everything he's done and hopefully he's
gonna be okay
speaking of great people and people that
have done a fantastic job
I have Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
with us and I'd like to ask Mike to say
a few words and then I think what we'll
do in order to get him back to the State
Department we'll take some questions and
we'll then go on with the rest of what
I'm gonna say then we'll take some
questions after that and then vice
president pence will take over so Mike
Pompeo Bruce Thank You mr. president
under the president's leadership my team
and I at the State Department are doing
our part to protect the American people
from the virus and importantly to get
them home as you know when many
countries shut down their rail lines
their busses their infrastructure
systems the capacity to get out of those
countries they were trapped they were
stranded the State Department swung into
action since January 29th we have now
repay treated over 50,000 United States
citizens back to their homes for more
than 90 countries more than 490 flights
back to the United States from all
across the world this this worldwide
scale of our
patreon efforts is without parallel in
our lifetime we are coordinating with
foreign governments militaries Airport
authorities medical units transportation
companies hotels you name it we're
working with them to make sure the
American people get back to be with
their families you can see behind me the
map of the flights that we have brought
back people from all across the world
every day I get a chance to hear some of
the remarkable stories from our team let
me give you just a couple of examples
our mission in Peru working with the
Peruvian military and police forces to
send riverboats up the up the river to
get citizens that were stranded deep
inside the Amazon forest our mission in
Nepal made sure their woman who was
running low on medication could get what
she needed a pharmacy before tea before
boarding an evacuation flight that
brought her back here in Honduras after
the government imposed very strict 24/7
curfew enclosed airports our embassy
sprang into action for stranded
Americans thousands of them three oh boy
told one of our consular officers just
before he boarded the flight thank you
for helping me get back home to my dad
pretty neat
we received similar messages from lots
of people they're proud to know that the
country will not leave them stranded
we're going to get them back home one
woman wrote quote I was in tears when I
received the email approving our flight
back to the United States god bless the
United States of America and the nether
said I felt like I had allies there that
actually treated me like a person or a
family member not just a number the
repatriation task force the State
Department a consular officers have done
great work I want to thank our partners
in the Department of Defense who have
helped with some of these flights back
home and other government agencies our
sisters and brothers across the United
States government in this administration
that have helped get these people back
and then lastly aside from our
repatriation efforts we continue to help
countries around the world as well we've
got cDC officials helping these
countries with expertise and all the
things that these countries need to get
their citizens safe and healthy and back
so that we can get the economy all
across the world the global economy back
on its feet when this crisis is over
Thank You mr. president
a little while we'll see if anybody has
any questions for Secretary of State
anybody please mr. secretary that's an
amazing effort that you have made how do
you know when you're done because I
imagine there are Americans on all
corners of the world and you're always
someone's gonna pop up and say I want to
go home now it's a great it's a great
question we still have several thousand
people that we're working they they
identify themselves every day new people
find themselves in difficult place look
we're gonna be done when people can
travel on their own again these people
traveled abroad on vacations or with
their church and we're intending to get
back on their own we hope that day comes
pretty soon where they don't have to
rely on the State Department to get them
back home but know this in the in the
meantime we're devoting all the
resources we have to get them there in
often in difficult places they're not in
the capitol near the airport or the
roads are closed and so it's not just a
matter of getting a flight down there
there's a lot of work that has to be
done to coordinate to make it all happen
and get those people available so
they're sitting there when the flight
lands they can get on the plane and then
we can get them Beckham and we still
have several thousand we're working on
it we chip away at that number every day
but new citizens go to the State
Department website identify themselves
and say I need a little bit of help in
some way can we do our best to get that
to them just as quickly as we can we're
gonna keep it up as long as we have
resources to do it and there's a meet
yes sir these staffers have tested
positive for coronavirus that they've
been tested or they going into
quarantine and and what does this do to
diplomatic efforts overseas if you're
pulling 50,000 people out of state cap
our national capitalist nation capitals
all over the world so the vast majority
50,000 weren't our officers these were
ordinary citizens who were there
traveling for business or for commercial
or further trip of a lifetime we've seen
some of that in the cruise ships but of
course they're stranded all over the
world so our embassies say for the one
that is in wuhan which we did pull
everybody out of the rest of our
facilities around the world are all open
we've had a handful of our folks now
test positive but we feel like we have a
good handle on it and we're doing
everything we can to make sure that not
just the State Department officials but
our department defense colleagues that
are working on these missions as well
and doing so in a way that
dueces risk to them and their well-being
also do you feel like china help with
helpful information from the united
states and will there be any
consequences for that you know it's this
is not the time for retribution but it
is still the time for clarity and
transparency we're still working on this
problem since they're still data that
these good people need so that they can
perform their analysis of how to both
develop therapeutics and a vaccine and
to understand where this virus is so
every country china included every
country needs to be transparent about
what's going on in their country need to
share that data we share ours with the
world so that the best scientists in the
world can get to the right conclusions
and bring this economy this global
economy back to the place that we all
want it to be as quickly as we can every
country has that responsibility
it started in China and so they have
that special responsibility to get it
right quickly and fast ask every country
as we move forward in the days and weeks
that make sure we share that do it do it
right do it well when we do we'll get
this thing back on they have shared
their data sooner with the United States
yeah every country has an obligation to
share that information accurately timely
completely transparently and thoroughly
just as quickly as they can gather it
well we'll leave for another time to
evaluate how everyone did in that thank
you thank you Secretariat the question
the World Health Organization has a
fundraising drive for about seven
hundred billion dollars for coronavirus
resources China has only donated 20
million the United States actually has
donated less so do you feel that China
should be giving more to this World
Health Organization that prevents
comments on the u.s. donation at this
point we're reading our funding with
respect to the World Health Organization
now this is very consistent what
President Trump said since the beginning
of his campaign organizations have to
work they have to deliver the outcomes
for which they were intended and we need
to make sure that not only the World
Health Organization but every
international organization that we take
taxpayer money and give it to them for
the benefit of America we need to make
sure it's delivering on those
spare dollars the World Health
Organization is no different in that
respect we have they have to execute on
the mission that they are designed to
achieve and we've seen with respect to
the World Health Organization here we
are we have we have it hasn't
accomplished what it was intended to
deliver mr. secretary you said that full
the staffers have tested positive are
they going to get the hydroxychloroquine
treatment is that going to be made
available to personnel overseas I don't
know the answer to that but but but know
that we'll deliver the best medical care
every place we can some of them are in
difficult places where there's not a lot
of medical help and we've done our best
to move that medical assistance forward
to them in the field can you give us an
update on the numbers you're seeing
about coronavirus cases in Iran and
whether or not you have any updates on
so with respect to our assistance to
Iran we've offered from the first day we
knew that the virus had struck the
people of Iran we offered humanitarian
assistance I regret that they they chose
not to take that I've heard I've heard
people talking about sanctions they're
know the world should know there are no
sanctions that prevent humanitarian
assistance medical supplies
pharmaceuticals from going to Iran we
offer at American assistance we've tried
to help other countries get assistance
in there as well had some ability to do
that I don't have any better data than
what you've seen publicly than I could
share with you with respect to the
extent of the virus inside of Iran
so you've seen we're making sure that we
have what we need for the American
people whether that's gloves
I'll let the vice president talk to
numbers on that but at this point what
we are doing in terms of assistance is
providing what most of these countries
need to learn how to do surveillance
themselves to learn how to conduct tests
themselves to learn the things that can
reduce the peak in their countries those
the kind of things and we've been doing
this you should know the United States
has been incredibly generous we have CDC
officials like no other country in the
world out helping these nations build
out their health care global epidemic
healthcare infrastructure it's good
people like that you see sitting to my
right they've been working on this all
their life all around the world putting
these countries in a place where they're
better prepared for a virus like this
one
of any US diplomats or US officials
contracted the virus as they have tried
to rescue u.s. citizens abroad not that
I'm aware of
not that I'm aware but it's there's no
doubt I remember when we sent our team
to get our officials and about 800
American citizens non-government
citizens that were living in Wuhan I
remember when we sent one of our first
repatriation flights in there we were
very careful we sent trained
professionals in but they were going
into a very very difficult very fraught
place we were blessed they all got back
with no one having contracted the virus
on that trip I'm not aware of any of our
officials that have had the virus
attacked them while they were performing
their functions trying to get people
back and so we have a number of State
Department officials who have who have
covered 19 now and are working their way
through in fact we've had three
fatalities of local employees not us
direct hires but local people who were
working for the State Department in
embassies around the world we've had
three fatalities so far so there have
been some calls on the World Health
Organization for a leadership change
there I was wondering what your thoughts
are on that senator martha mcsalley for
example is called for doctor
I don't want it look it this is not the
time to be to be doing that kind of
change there there'll be a lot of time
to look back and see how the World
Health Organization performed in the
meantime what our task is is to preserve
and protect the American taxpayers to
make sure that our resources don't go to
places that aren't going to deliver on
behalf of the American people in the
world and president drop and I are
determined to do that China has a
responsibility to get correct figures
how would you broadly characterize
cooperation with China right now there's
lots of places we've been cooperating
right they're providing us assistance
where we need it there are places on the
ground now where we do have access to
the data we need and we're deeply
appreciative that they've said they want
to cooperate we're completely prepared
to cooperate with them that cooperation
means sharing data being transparent
being upfront allowing information to
flow freely that's our expectation not
just of China though of every country
that is in this place today we
collectively we have to work our way
through this and to do that you have to
have really good data okay okay Thank
You mr. president thank you all Thanks
okay thank you very much just a few days
we've delivered nearly 11 million n95
masks to hotspots around the country as
you know including 6.6 million to New
York and New Jersey 1.8 million to
Chicago 1.7 million to Detroit and 837
thousand to New Orleans I spoke with the
governor of Louisiana a little while ago
and they're doing really pretty well
much better than they thought they'll be
using fewer beds as you know we built a
hospital we're about set to complete
another Hospital and it's there's even a
possibility that won't they won't need
it that's what we discussed today we've
shipped out more than 8,000 ventilators
and we have 10,000 almost 10,000 seat
and an additional two thousand two
hundred new li manufactured ventilators
come online on Monday we're gonna be
sending them to various locations just
in case they need them my
administration's working with Philips to
double their production of ventilators
by May and ultimately quadruple
production by later this year
high-quality ventilators we're
eliminating bureaucratic barriers to
pave the way for Philips major
investments in American manufacturing
sites and sales this will help to ensure
that our country can permanently produce
enough ventilators in the future that we
can do them by ourselves we're gonna
have a big stockpile when we're finished
and we expect to be sending quite a few
to other countries to help them after
we're finished and even now we're a
couple of countries are really really in
dire need and it looks like our
projections were right on ventilators
and some states that were thinking that
would need thousands of more than they
thought
will are now already taken care of which
we're very happy about
in addition beginning in May will be
receiving almost 300 million new face
masks we're gonna have masks of about
300 million they'll be starting to be
delivered in May and during the month of
June so we're ordering a big stockpile
and we're thinking about doing an extra
200 million should we need them or for
them or for the stockpile so we'll be in
a position to have something Incredibles
that'll be a total of 500 million masks
and today 750,000 new protective gowns
landed in Dallas Texas as a result of a
partnership led by the federal
government DuPont and FedEx and that's
been a great partnership that's worked
very well so we have 600 and we have
750,000 new protective gowns and these
are at a high level very high quality as
American industry steps up to help so
our America's doctors and scientists 10
drugs are now in clinical trials and my
administration is taking unpressed
actions to make new therapies and
treatments available without delay the
the doctors the lab technicians the
companies I spoke to him yesterday I
spoke again today they are coming up
with things that are I think I hope in
the very near future are gonna be very
very special very important our national
stockpile is now equipped with nearly 30
million hydroxy chloroquine pills so
we're up to about 30 million we're
distributing by the millions you read
about state representative Karen
Whitsett who I very much appreciate her
going public but she was I think very
very much helped by this bill she saw
what I was saying on television she
thought she was in very bad shape I
don't want to go further than that but
you see her story you know her story
she's a highly respected state rep from
Michigan and she did a she did a I think
she did a great service what she what
she's done she's in terrific shape she
looks fantastic and she was very
generous with her statements in addition
the Zathura my son and and zinc they say
is Inc you should add zinc now as all
has to be recommended by doctors
physicians but they say zinc I want to
throw that out there because that's
where they seem to be having the best
result so you add the zinc and the raw
myosin and it's been we've had a lot of
good stories a lot of good stories and
we have almost 30 million doses so we've
got a lot I want to thank Prime Minister
Modi of India for allowing us to have
what we requested from before the the
problem arose and he was he was terrific
we'll remember it later today the CDC
will release further guidance to help
ensure critical infrastructure workers
can perform their job safely after
potential exposure to the virus and so
working on that the question was asked a
little while ago about the World Health
Organization and as you know they made a
statement on June 1 January 14th I guess
it was that there was no human to human
transmission well there was they
probably made that statement in the
second or third week of December in
addition but they made it very
powerfully on January 14th and they
criticized me very strongly when I said
that we're going to shut down flights
coming in from China and especially from
certain parts of China but from China
generally we were criticized very badly
so last year and for many years hundreds
of millions of dollars has been paid to
the World Health Organization hundreds
of millions of dollars a year and last
year was 452 million dollars in China
paid 42 million before that it was 500
million in China paid less than 40
million and before that it was similar
numbers in the 400 300 s and sometimes
even in the five hundreds of millions of
dollars and China would do
proportionally at just a small fraction
of that number and I think they have to
get their priorities right and their
priorities are that everybody has to be
treated properly every country and it
doesn't seem that way does it doesn't
seem that way so we're going to do study
investigation and we're going to make a
determination as to what we're doing in
the meantime we're holding back we're
going to we want to say very unfair so
the United States
452 million dollars compared to 42
million dollars that's to the World
Health Organization that's not good
that's not good not fair not fair at all
and other countries as you know also
gave very substantially less than the
United States
and the world w-h-o world health got it
wrong I mean they got it very wrong in
many ways they were wrong they also
minimize the threat very strongly and
not good I want to take this opportunity
to express the thanks of an extremely
grateful nation to the Americans who go
to work every day especially in these
critical industries in the midst of the
pandemic to care for and protect and
feed American people including medical
personnel law enforcement first
responders food suppliers sanitation
workers and somebody mentioned any would
you please specifically call-out
cashiers and clerks at grocery stores
who are in danger during the during the
pandemic during the epidemic they're in
danger they're really in great danger
and they've been incredible and I want
to call them out to cashiers and books
we grew up with cashiers and clerks and
grocery stores and they've been great
and they've really been true American
here so I want to call them out because
they're working hard and they're working
in conditions that aren't ideal but soon
they'll be ideal again as we mourn the
terrible loss of life for this and from
this this grave pandemic we're seeing
signs that our aggressive strategy to
slow the spread is working the number of
new cases is stabilizing the number of
beds necessary in so many locations I
was watching this morning New York I was
watching Louisiana you see what's going
on the numbers are changing and they're
changing rapidly and soon will be over
that curve will be over the top and will
be headed in the right direction I feel
strongly about that some terrible days
ahead but we're gonna have some some
wonderful days ahead and we're gonna get
this behind us this terrible thing
behind us some people will never be able
to forget if they had a loved one if
they had
great friend or friend but we're gonna
get it behind us this is a tribute to
the discipline and the devotion of the
American people what we've accomplished
if every American continues to strictly
adhere to social distancing guidelines
we can defeat the invisible enemy and
save countless lives that we could do it
much more quickly we are hopefully
heading toward a final stretch the light
at the end of the tunnel as I was saying
as we continue to wage all-out medical
war to defeat the virus we're also
fighting an economic war to ensure we
can quickly turn to full financial
strength we have to get our country back
we have to get going everybody wants to
get going yesterday I asked Congress to
provide an additional 250 billion
dollars to expand to the incredibly
successful paycheck protection program
you've seen what's gone on there it's
incredible actually which is allowing
our small businesses to keep employees
on the payroll and get ready for the
opening like a second opening to protect
millions of American jobs I'm asking
Congress to pass additional funding for
this program this week as soon as
possible and I think we have pretty good
understanding with the Democrats
hopefully it's going to be bipartisan we
do not have time for the partisan games
and we don't want that the obstruction
or totally unrelated agendas we want to
do this for the small businesses and the
workers and we can do a phase four and a
phase four will be later this will be an
expansion of what we've already done
because it's so successful the 350
billion will be expanded by hopefully
250 and if you look at the kind of loans
thousands tens of thousands of loans to
small businesses it's a it's a great
thing to see turn out to be more
successful and more productive than
anybody would have thought but Democrats
and Republicans are coming together to
get that job done that's a very
important job in recent days and days
we'll restore America's health and
economic might but also dimensions of
our national strength will be brought
together I think stronger than I think
we have a chance to be stronger than
ever before we've learned a lot and we
have tremendous stimulus now tremendous
stimulus and we're going for more
hopefully we'll be doing an
infrastructure bill so we can rebuild
our roads and highways and bridges and
tunnels and all of the things that we
should be doing for our country we're
going to rebuild our country not other
countries where they don't even
appreciate it as our citizens persevere
through this present challenge we're
renewing American unity and we're
replenishing American will and we are
witnessing new American valor each and
every day we see it every day the daring
and determination of our people in this
crisis reminds us that no matter how
hard it gets no matter what obstacles we
must overcome Americans will keep on
fighting to victory and we will secure
the glorious future that our citizens so
richly deserve especially after going
through this nightmare
this evil beast so we're getting very
close and hopefully it will hopefully
it's on the other side and it will end
soon and I think it will and I just
think that the people of this country
are fantastic so we'll take a few
questions and then vice president will
take over please go ahead please thank
you sir president ABC is reporting that
your intelligence intelligence committee
was warning about the virus as early as
member and produced a detailed report
about the outbreak in China when did you
first learn about the intelligence and
could you have acted on it then well I
learned when I started when I learned
about the gravity of it was sometime
just prior to closing the country to
China and when we closed up the flights
coming in from China and various other
elements and then as you know we closed
up to Europe so I don't know exactly but
I'd like to see the information yeah
please
a lot of Americans want to see
businesses reopened go back so to write
more than anybody
so what specifically has to happen for
you to feel that it's safe to reopen the
country and what is your plan to do that
well I think we can say that we have to
be on that downside of that slope and
heading to a very strong direction that
this thing is gone now we can do it in
phases we can go to some areas which you
know some areas are much less effective
than others but it would be nice to be
able to open with a big bang and open up
our country or certainly most of our
country and I think we're going to do
that so and you look at what's happening
I would say we're ahead of schedule now
you hate to say it too loudly because
all of a sudden things don't happen but
I think we will be sooner rather than
later but we'll be sitting down with the
professionals we'll be sitting down with
many different people and making a
determination and those meetings will
start taking place fairly soon until the
health experts tell you it's safe to do
it yeah I would rely very heavily on
them you for monitoring and testing that
you're looking at yeah we're putting in
yeah we're putting in very heavy testing
systems we have the best testing so when
we look at cases just want to get out
himself to anybody I'm not gonna result
in the country but I'm looking at
countries that are showing less cases
than testing we're testing more than
anybody and use you so exponentially
more than anybody by far if the lie
program in our testings become I think
it'll end up being a big strength in
fact the other countries other countries
that the media talked about are now
calling us for what are we doing and how
are we doing it so quickly and that
can't be true where are we getting these
tests because our tests are really good
now they've been proven to be very
accurate yes please Thank You president
talk about two quick questions yeah one
on infrastructure members of your
administration and members of Congress
have pointed out the top paid federal
employee it's not the president it's at
the head of the Tennessee Valley
Authority and he made 8 million dollars
last year and some ridiculous it's
ridiculous I think it's the highest paid
government long before I got here you
said Tennessee Valley Authority right
has to be the highest paid man in any
government makes approximately eight or
nine million dollars I don't know the
gentleman but he's got a heck of a job
he gets paid a lot of money what's been
there for a long while has day that's a
separate yeah that's separate but I'm
talking about the separate the we just
have some new people going on the board
I know but as you know that's a quasi
public agency and whoever the head of
the agency is that person makes a lot of
money which is an amazing thing right
and when we want them to do something
they're not there for us let me switch
once more oh here we can see the people
assets but I'm talking about the the we
just have some new people going on the
board I know but as you know that's a
quasi public agency and whoever the head
of the agency is that person makes a lot
of money which is an amazing thing right
and when we want them to do something
they're not there for us that's not good
that's not good the same been there for
a long time that's been a story for a
long dinner since in April that you
would support reducing that salaries
part of the infrastructure bill
reducing it by a lot my other question
is that raise job in the history of
government almost certainly if you're
into money Tennessee Valley Authority
that's right go ahead I'm so I'm waiting
for somebody to ask me about that it's
been it's been bothering me for a long
time too gone
one of the biggest rating hits of the
coronaviruses aside from these briefings
has been a show on Netflix called Tiger
king yeah and the man who's the star of
this was a former zoo owner who's
serving a 22-year prison sentence he's
asking you for a pardon saying he was
unfairly convicted oh God
your son yesterday jokingly said that
you know he was going to advocate for it
and I was wondering if you've seen the
show and if you have any thoughts on
cordoning show which son must be done I
had a feeling whose time is that what he
said oh boy I don't know I know nothing
about it has 22 years for what what did
he do allegedly hired someone to murder
an animal rights activist metal that you
can dig that it was do you think he
didn't do it are you on his side are you
are you recommending a pardon no I'm not
advocating as a reporter you're not
allowed to do that you'd be criticized
by these would you recommend a pardon I
don't think you have a question I'll
take a look last week your top experts
were saying that we should expect a
hundred thousand and two hundred forty
thousand deaths in this country you've
been talking about how it looks like
maybe things are plateauing are these
numbers now being revised downward I
know you don't want people to stop
social distancing and that sort of thing
but what can you tell us about the
numbers I did are they right yeah my
impression Jim is those were the numbers
that were set and they were set as an
expectation from quite a while ago I
think we're just doing much better than
those numbers if either of you would
like to talk about that a fair question
there's the idea of toting around that
they set randomly high numbers so that
then Trump could just claim that you
want with lower so and I think all of
you many of you have done the analysis
of the same models that we utilized and
if you do the models of the models you
end up with that range at the same time
we carefully looked at Italy and Spain
and we are doing much better in many
cases
and several other countries and we're
trying to understand that we believe
that our healthcare delivery system in
the United States is quite extraordinary
I know many of you are watching the act
now model and the ìiî hme model from and
they have consistently decreased the
number the mortality from over almost 90
thousand or eighty eighty six thousand
down to eighty one thousand and now down
to sixty one thousand that is modeled on
what America is doing that's what's
happening right and I think what has
been so remarkable I think to those of
us who have been in the science field
for so long is how important behavioral
change is and how amazing Americans are
in adapting to and following through on
these behavioral changes and that's
what's changing the rate of new cases
and that's what will change the
mortality going forward because now
we're into the time period a full
mitigation that should be reflected
within the coming weeks of decreasing
mortality I mean that's what we really
hope to see Ron we are impressed by the
American people and I think models are
models I've always worked on validating
I spent my life validating models all
over the world and that's why we do
surveys and surveillance and we make
sure that what we think is right is
right I think this will change how
people look at respiratory diseases
because it will change what is possible
when the globe and particularly the
American people do this level of
mitigation exactly one as I talked about
yesterday we are still so we are still
in off really of the American people
strength in this and following through
yeah I'm gonna do that I'm gonna ask Bob
to come up just for a second director I
I think that's it we have we've done
they have done everybody has done
everybody a great job so those were
original projections and we don't want
to say anything about beating it yet but
I think we will have a very good chance
to beat them very substantial about this
Thank You mr. president I just want to
add to what ambassador Burke said I mean
this is a consequence of the commitment
of the American people you know a lot of
us have always had challenges changing
behavior whether if it's exercising
regularly or different habits of smoking
when it when it when it affects us but I
mean remarkable to watch here is how the
American public has changed their
behavior when it protects the vulnerable
I think that's really what I'm so proud
to see just yes or no question yesterday
you said you had not seen Peter Tavares
memo on coronavirus back in January
February
were you ever breached on those memos
did you ever discuss those memos with
anybody I don't remember that I've now
seen the memo I saw it it was Peter says
a lot of memos you to see the memo as
you know world health was saying that
was not correct because at the time they
called it wrong but I didn't see the
memo but I acted as quickly as people
were shocked they reacted so quickly and
everybody thought I was wrong because I
did act so quickly as you know that's a
fabric respect to closing the borders
with respect there's not only to China
but with Europe I close the borders mark
and I think that was very important now
but no I didn't see the memo it didn't
but I have seen it since yeah
warned against politicizing I agree with
that and he said that I think that that
consequence of this political it a
sensation could actually create more
body bags it's a pretty pivotal in egde
and what uh what do you believe the
consequences of the u.s. pulling out its
funding up the W I think you say more
body bags I think we would have done and
he would have been much better serving
the people that he's supposed to serve
if they gave a correct analysis I mean
everything was I said China centric
everything was gonna be fine
no human-to-human keep the borders open
he wanted me to keep the borders open I
closed the borders despite him and that
was a hard decision to make at the time
we were all together we made a decision
against the World Health Organization so
when he says politicizing he's
politicizing that shouldn't be but look
we spend four hundred and fifty billion
dollars four hundred and fifty two
billion dollars almost five hundred
billion last year hundreds of billions
in previous years and they got to do
better than that from when you don't
know about politics I can't believe he's
talking about politics when look at the
relationship they have to China so China
spends 42 million we spend four hundred
and fifty million and everything seems
to be China's way that's not right it's
not fair to us and honestly it's not
fair to the world okay question in the
back yeah
a couple of reports from a couple
different outlets that Jared Kushner's
team is seeking to create a national
coronavirus database such a tracking
system for patients who've been
diagnosed now his spokesperson said that
that's not true yeah it's not I have
never heard about it doesn't sound like
a bad idea actually but I have not heard
about that I don't know if I'd be okay I
have to see it but it sounds very
scientific and it sounds like it could
be good based on scientific but it also
has to do with rights and lots of
different constitutional questions I
have not heard that at all so some
people are concerned it would be like
the post 9/11 Patriot Act that it
ultimately led to the FISA abuse are
there any difference either abusive
which I was the one abused and a couple
of other people in all fairness no I
don't know anything about it I haven't
heard it I mean I'll speak to him I
don't I don't think so they would have
told me I would have known about it
please because smaller casinos and
businesses that make profit in Nevada
from gaming in Nevada found out they're
not eligible for the carers Act PPP
money is this and I talked to one of
remember who said you leave because of
the number of employees because of the
numbering point this wall business and
they thought gaming would be it would
not be treated any differently than any
other business with this was it well I
can look at that I could look it's a
great state and I will take a look at
that strong yeah are you talking only
the smaller casinos yeah I'll take a
look at that fine
I don't mind that please yeah we'll take
a look yo where's the really so not
matter but I'll look at nobody photo the
great state they do a great job so I'm
gonna look at it very only I understand
what they mean
please Thank You mr. president terms of
the economy what if you urge Americans
to go
back to work and they'll listen to you
would you leave that up to the
governor's to businesses to citizens to
decide when when it's safe to stop
social distancing well when you say they
don't listen I think they're gonna
listen they want to go back everybody
wants they going stir-crazy they've been
in those houses and those apartments and
there I mean they've really been they've
done a great job again when you look the
question was just asked about you know
about how we doing compared to
projections those were just original
projections the big projection being 2.2
million people would die if you did you
know that was the one decision we made
close it up that was a big decision so
this is a big thing Trump is now doing
saying listen the the comparison is 2.2
million that's if you do nothing like
there's not a leader on earth who who
would do nothing maybe the Brazil dude
but I guess 1.5 to 2.2 million people
would die if we didn't close it up a lot
of people so if we do a number that's
tremendously smaller than that now if we
did close it up the numbers got to a
hundred to 220 million people so if we
can stay substantially under the hundred
which was the original projection I
think we all did a very good job even
though it's a lot of people say it right
for that by me first
well right now we're imeem we're doing
well in terms of the numbers I can't
tell you in terms of the date careful
now you know we don't want to we don't
want to go down and then right can start
going up if we're not careful so we have
to be careful as far as distancing
social distancing and other things
certainly for a while you know at some
point that's going away we'll be able to
sit next to each other and everything
like we have all our lives it's a very
unique thing this has not happened
anything like this of this magnitude
since 1917 1918 the great pandemic that
was that was something but ya know I
people want to sit next to each other at
restaurants they want to sit next to
each other like normal at a football
game baseball game basketball game high
game no we want to go back to life now
the first period of time maybe we'll go
a little bit slower and maybe we'll be
talking about distance
but at some point we expect to be back
like it was before and hopefully it'll
never happen hopefully it will if it
does happen it's going to be in a
hundred years from now the last one 1917
that's something that's a long time ago
and that was a that was a horrible thing
Jim good yeah get back to what you were
saying yesterday about people going to
Wisconsin and voting yeah in the middle
of this pandemic really putting their
lives on the line and you said well if
they do that vote by mail perhaps we'll
have voter fraud in this country that's
one of that few voters in five states
you talk Colorado Hawaii Washington
Oregon all vote-by-mail can you or the
White House staff where you can't and
provide any evidence to back up your
claim the mail and voting is wife with
fraud like the example you gave of
people working your rooms filling out a
false balance there and where is the
evidence the I think there's a lot of
evidence but we'll provide you some K
and as evidence that's being compiled
just like it's being compiled in the
state of California where they settled
with Judicial Watch saying that a
million people should not have you just
one load into thinking you saw that did
you wait excuse me well I'm just telling
you I'm telling you in California in the
gray Southern California they settled
and we could have gone a lot further
Judicial Watch settled where they agree
that a million people should not have
voted where they were a hundred and
fifteen years old and lots of things and
people were voting in that place what I
see and you know every one of those
states that you mentioned is a state
that happens to be won by the Democrats
and if you have a position like me where
it's registered you're here and we're
voting someplace where I'm not I haven't
left the White House and I guess months
other than to you know ask Achanta you
know wavered goodbye to New York which
by the way is now going as you know
being used for the purpose that we're
talking about which a lot of people
wanted wait a minute
he's not talking about what about
talking about hasn't user your concern
certainly hasn't but if you're a senior
citizen and if you're somebody that
needs it I'm all for it but they have to
be very careful because you know the
things with bundling and all of the
things that are happening with bundling
by Mayella oh my god where thousands of
votes are gathered and I don't think an
hour does it but the public oats are
gathered in the pumpkin and they're
dumped in a location and then all of a
sudden you lose elections if you think
you're gonna win re-election fraud
happening with mail-in ballots is from
Republicans I'm going and I'm not going
to stand for it our voting system first
of all we should have voter ID when you
vote you should have voter ID and if you
send something in you should be sure as
a state and as a country you should be
sure that that vote is meaningful and
it's not just made fraudulently because
there's a lot of fraudulent voting going
on in this country this country should
have voter ID okay let's do now the
issue didn't answer for a while it's
incredible
that are being distributed across the
country through the eHealth data system
is that OAM how systematically is your
task force of watching this well I think
it's very systematic you know we're just
away the hydroxy all through the country
it's being distributed in large numbers
with c-span cameras don't cut to her cuz
she's not even supposed to be in there
29 million doses that we went to 30
million doses but we have it coming in
all throughout the country and much of
its being distributed in fact it'll
start going down what we have in our
stockpile and again it said you know I
hope it works again I'm not a doctor as
you possibly have found out I'm not a
doctor but I'm a person with common
sense and right we've had some very good
results over the course including a
woman who just reported it two days ago
yes I think no looking we're looking to
provide it in many different ways
in many ways were in certain instances
we've been asked in the case of Michigan
we've been asked who the governor of
Michigan would like to I think she's
become a big fan of it as a medication
as a as something that's going to help
with this horrible virus and we're
delivering it to the governments of
various states when they ask so certain
states are asking certain governments
are asking and we're delivering it
directly to the government Wow
thank you very much we know many people
around the world
I'll pay close attention to this
conference so I'll behave fulfill it for
your friend yet where are you from I'm
from Taiwan good yes
on behalf of probably a group I would
like to ask you two questions first
question is that the French president
Mahone called
President rouhani and say the Euro has
started to ship the medical goods to
Iran where you can see the medical goods
yes that doesn't bother me yeah so will
you finish sending medical goods to a
Renault okay yeah so the other question
is that the world also pay attention to
the US election so we are also we know
that the Bernie Sanders has yeah he
didn't really drop out he didn't really
drink what about his delegates I mean he
but he's gonna keep his delegates and
which is sort of interesting he's gonna
keep his delegates that he'd like to get
more now is he dropping out or not
that's not dropping out no he's kaga
delegates and then you want more
delegates before you get to the
convention well he may win more
it's a weird deal going on there and I
don't know why President Obama hasn't
supported Joe Biden a long time ago can
said he wouldn't he allows wrong ask a
question he'll come out I'm sure he's
got to come out at some point cuz he
certainly doesn't want to see me for
four more years we're not we we think a
little bit differently no one with
comments you know what I'll tell you it
does amaze me that President Obama
hasn't supported sleepy Joe it just
hasn't happened wasn't gonna happen
there when is it gonna happen he says
wait isn't he he knows something that
you don't know Obama's just staying out
of it till the primaries officially over
to not be divisive it'll be interesting
but with Bernie I saw his standard fare
today I watched and I hope that a lot of
Bernie Sanders people just like they did
last time we got a tremendous percentage
of Bernie people and I think they voted
for me largely because of trade because
Bernie and I agree on trade we agree
that the United States has been ripped
off like we're trying to poach Bernie
voters it's it's very clear he's gonna
be doing it so I've done a lot about it
and I'm doing more about it and we've
made incredible trade deals including us
MCA
to deal with China and then all of a
sudden that gets disturbed by this virus
situation but China has to spend almost
250 billion dollars on purchasing our
products
forty to fifty billion dollars with our
farmers and the Bernie Sanders people
are big believers on what I'm saying on
trade and I got a lot of them in the
last election that surprised people but
it didn't surprise me now those are
great people so great people but I've
got a smaller percentage than the
percentage that in 2012 2008 flipped
from Hillary to McCain elegance the
delegates he's not giving up his
delegates he's keeping them and he said
he wants to get more of them and I think
he's doing it to negotiate I assume but
I don't know that's like that that's a
hard thing to do finally somebody knows
something with a escalation what is your
message to them ahead of their meeting
tomorrow will be us consider we already
cut you know we're like very market
oriented if you look at Texas and if you
look at North Dakota and if you look at
some of our states that do this very
well they've already cut way back you
know they cut back automatically but in
the case of Russia in the case of Saudi
Arabia they increased production at a
time when you didn't need it and then
they got hit by the virus which knocked
out 40% of the market and now they're
flooded with oil look I just say this
you have two countries that are getting
hurt very badly Russia is getting her
that's a primary source and Saudi Arabia
that Sarah definitely their primary
source and it doesn't make sense that
they flooded the market for whatever
reason they did that for themselves it's
a argument that they had and I think
they'll straighten it out a lot of
progress has been made over the last
week really making and it'll be
interesting to see what comes out of
OPEC tomorrow but OPEC obviously for
many years I used to think OPEC was very
unfair I hate it affect you wanna know
the truth I hated it because it was a
fix but somewhere along the line that
broke down and it went the opposite way
and we have a tremendously powerful
energy industry in this country now
number one in the world and I don't want
those jobs being lost
okay so what will you do if they go
we'll see I have a lot of options please
a lot of good options Jeff beauties I
might like it even more now you want to
watch let's see what happens hopefully
they can make a deal that's getting me
so very vague
now that the I am a cheap model
specifically has been adjusted down to
61 thousand by page when are we gonna
open back up can you give us a better
date is it gonna be April 30th May 1st
you cincone and adjusted back down
61,000 what was adjusted by the I am the
I am aging model I originally predicted
like between a hundred and ten that's
still a big number right 61 right that's
a big number
go ahead it's like children can you give
us a more specific date well it'd be me
first I had a date and I thought it was
a very aspirational date it's turning
out to be very interesting cuz a lot of
good things are happening by Easter but
I had a very aspirational a miracle date
I didn't think he could make it I didn't
say we would do it by Easter but I said
boy wouldn't that be great to shoot for
Easter that would be a great day a
beautiful day very important day to a
lot of people like me right and like
some of you in the room maybe all of you
in the room frankly but any Jesus is a
very important when they saw ahead
aspirationally I said let's see if we
can do it at Easter you know but I said
it would be very tough and I was
criticized for that so I don't like
giving dates and that wasn't a date that
was just an aspiration that would have
been incredible but I don't think we're
gonna be very far behind and some of
these models are looking like Easter is
gonna be a very important date anyway
because of the curve I mean it's hitting
the top and it's starting to come down
and one person said Easter is looking
like a good time not quite a good time
for that for heading down understanding
you need like six weeks of it coming
down to get back to a reasonable point
where it wouldn't immediately reinfect
that it's crazy he said Tony they need
far less beds than you I said well good
because we're building a thousand room
edition
we built them a thousand the beds and
now we're building another thousand and
I said listen is there a way that we
don't build I don't want to build them
if they don't need them in New York the
Javits isn't too heavily used it's ready
to go
two thousand nine hundred beds plus we
now have the ship set for kovat if they
want to use it and we're using it for
governor Murphy and New Jersey so we'll
see what happens but you know the
numbers are coming way down the
ventilators were all set we have a lot
to go if we want but I so understand
nothing's coming down yet the rate of
increase has slowed down Trump doesn't
get I mean who cares just facts right
guys additional ventilators for some of
the countries that are our allies and
our friends and in even if they're not
our allies that our friends you're
saving human lives but I'd love to see
if we had some I mean we're making a lot
of ventilators right now we have a and
they take a while to make and they're
very expensive and they're very complex
to make but I'd love to be able to help
other countries once we're taken care of
but I just sent 100 ventilators to
Colorado and that was great senator
there was a terrific Senator Cory and
Eric Donnelly called me last night he
said could you get a hundred ventilators
for Colorado and we just sent them out
and they'll be there very shortly so but
it looks like we're in great shape from
the bed standpoint it looks like we're
in great shape from the ventilator
standpoint and you just heard I ordered
500 million masks 595 s and others and
surgical but we ordered 500 million mess
three hundred and two hundred and
they're going to be here very shortly so
we're really in great shape and we
started off with an empty cupboard so
I'm going to leave the Vice President
and his group to handle it and I will
see you probably tomorrow okay
thank you thank you very much thank you
very much that question was do you have
investments in hydroxychloroquine he
said no he's got about a thousand bucks
you'll come up if you want well good
evening everyone and to our fellow
Americans south west good afternoon
we find ourselves in the midst of a very
tough week for Americans in areas most
impacted by the coronavirus new york
city area new jersey louisiana continue
to focus resources and attention on
those areas and I know that the hearts
and prayers of the American people are
with with all of those communities but
in the wake of of more than 1.9 million
tests we see more than 400,000 Americans
have tested positive for the corona
virus and sadly we've lost more than
14,000 we okay sick we grieve but as the
Good Book says we do not grieve like
those who have no hope I've got in this
very special week I know that the faith
of millions of Americans is a comfort to
them the President and I spoke to more
than 10,000 faith leaders and we were
able to express to them our gratitude
for the way that they're strengthening
the communities that they serve but we
also find hope in the numbers that dr.
Burks will continue to reflect on today
let her as dr. Fauci explain yesterday
and in the days before the losses as
Grievous as they are that we are seeing
today are a reflection of people that
contracted the corona virus in many
cases before strong mitigation steps
were taken before the guidelines for
America fully took hold the cases
however in the new cases in the
hospitalizations are in fact a
reflection of the results of what the
American people are doing and I want to
echo the president's and dr. Burke
statements today about the extraordinary
work the American people are doing
because we continue to see a great
progress low and steady numbers in the
states of California and Washington
and in the New York metropolitan area in
New Jersey New Orleans metro area
Detroit Chicago and Boston we continue
to see evidence of stabilization that
should be an encouragement to every
American an encouragement that we may
may be reaching the point where the
impact of the corona virus is beginning
to level off but it also should be an
encouragement to every American to keep
doing what we are all doing heed the
guidance of your state and local
authorities and for every American
continue to put the White House corona
virus guidelines for America into effect
an area of particular concern we were
briefed on this morning is the city of
Philadelphia I spoke today to Governor
Tom wolf and as we begin to see early
trend lines in Philadelphia I assured
him that we were going to continue to
flow resources and support to that
community but our message to the people
of the Philadelphia area is now more
than ever a practice the social
distancing so that Philadelphia and and
to some extent even Pittsburgh do not
have to endure what other communities
before them have had to endure also
today at the president's direction we
hosted a conference call with every
Republican member of the House of
Representatives and every Democrat
member of the House of Representatives
every member and we express our
appreciation to Speaker Nancy Pelosi and
leader Kevin McCarthy for convening
these forums we brought together key
members of our task force team the
secretary of the Treasury discussed the
progress that we've made on paycheck
protection he reported to members of
Congress that so far we're working with
more than 3600 lenders across the
country and we've dispersed more than 98
billion dollars in forgivable loans now
these are loans that if small businesses
accept this money and use it to keep
people on their pay
over the next two months they'll be
completely forgiven a Treasury tonight
we'll be issuing a new FAQ frequently
asked questions document it will also
make it clear that lenders may use their
own closing documents for completing
loan applications and that information
is available at Treasury gov and sba.gov
as well dr. Burks dr. Fauci briefed the
members of Congress today on the latest
data they'll both reflect on that in a
moment we also had Admiral John below
chair talk about our control tower
system in the extraordinary flow of
supplies to critical areas across the
country we also briefed on the
disbursement of resources to local
hospitals of sima Burma and gave them an
update on what the Secretary of State
spoke about today it's remarkable to
think more than 50,000 Americans brought
back home through nearly 500 flights and
and we thank the members of Congress who
have worked with the state department to
identify family members and groups that
found themselves stranded overseas and
we were grateful for that in addition to
our interaction with members of Congress
today we spoke with the president of the
Henry Ford Hospital Bob Rainey it is the
Henry Ford Hospital that is conducting a
clinical trial for hydrochloric won he
expressed great enthusiasm for the work
that they had done they had a they had a
rather overwhelming response to the
initial trial which is beginning this
week with 3,000 people taking the
hydrochloric win or a placebo so they
dropped you to match it but what what
the president of the Henry Ford Hospital
told me is they'd like to expand the
test I put him in touch with Steve Hahn
and the FDA and we'll be adding several
more the thing is like there's already
plenty of chloroquine trials going on
you know the important stuff now is
looking at other things there's dozens
of other things here in Boston they're
starting a Navigon trial with three
hospitals we're gonna figure out the
chloroquine thing doing more trials does
not
unless you're trying to get one that
justifies continuing to promote it of
which may be their priority mister
declarations Vermont was the latest
approved and states have stood up some
27,000 National Guard that are aiding in
coronavirus response on the critical
subject of ventilators we do have
currently more than 8,000 ventilators in
our strategic national stockpile and
distributed more to the Navajo Nation at
a Colorado today but also today we
received the good news that the first
delivery of newly manufactured
ventilators from General Electric and
Hamilton arrived at the strategic
national stockpile and as the president
said we'll be adding newly manufactured
ventilators to our resources to be
available as as as the corona virus
epidemic reaches critical communities
around the country on the subject of the
air bridge four flights are scheduled to
arrive today primarily focused on gloves
for our incredible health care workers
one flight alone had nearly 19 million
gloves another eight million another 15
million and the light and the American
people I think would be very proud and
to see this vast array of now well more
than 50 flights that are bringing in
supplies from all over the world and
again working through FEMA we're
directing those resources with the
guidance of our scientific experts to
the communities most in need right as we
announced yesterday the White House
coronavirus task force has requested
that CDC and our team assembled data on
the unique impact that that we're seeing
reported on African Americans from the
corona virus dr. Fauci spoke about it
yesterday and will reflect on his
perspective on that as well tomorrow
with the Surgeon General and others on
the White House team will will be
speaking with leaders in the African
American community
and as dr. Fauci will reflect there are
have been historic challenges in the
health care of the Africa
african-american communities
particularly in our inner cities and now
more than ever I'll just say from my
heart
to all of the all of our
african-american family members now more
than ever practice the guidelines right
look after those most vulnerable people
that have underlying serious health
conditions it's more important than ever
that we all put those principles into
practice finally today I'm going to have
after we we hear from dr. fowey and dr.
Burks I'm going to ask dr. Redfield to
step up because today the CDC will be
publishing new guidance on essential
critical workers who have been exposed
to Kovan 19 but don't have any symptoms
don't have a temperature and don't have
any reason to believe that they have the
virus the present moment the guidance is
that if you if you have been in
proximity to someone who did test
positive for the corona virus that the
guidance of CDC is that that even with
essential critical workers in industries
from health care to food supply that we
ask people to stay home the 13 days the
new guidance tonight will hopefully make
make it clear that there would be an
opportunity for those people playing
such an incredible role in our nation's
response to be able to return to work
and to do so so y'all just get there's a
document that has already leaked so the
idea is if you've been in contact with
someone who had it but you've not had
symptoms you may you are in an essential
worker you'd be able to go back to work
taking your temperature twice a day and
wearing a mask or something along those
lines and it seems a little dicey to be
perfectly frank for Nia and Washington
State and now beginning to see numbers
of hospitalizations of going down and
new cases leveling and in some cases
going down
we all hope it is the beginning of a
trend but we also hope it is it's an
encouragement to every American to keep
doing what you're doing not just for
your own health for the health of your
loved ones but because we we want to
make sure that all of us are doing our
part to make sure that the fewest number
of Americans possible are exposed to the
coronavirus given the fact that this I
remind you is three times more
contagious than the flu each of us has a
role to play in in slowing the spread
that's what the 30 days to slow the
spread is all about it's about
protecting your health it's about making
sure that that our health care workers
are our and our health care system is
not is not overwhelmed by the
coronavirus and and ultimately it is
about saving lives we talk about the
numbers and I'm going to ask dr. Burks
to come up and reflect on them but I
think all of us know this is one
American at a time is he quite a
heartbreak at a time
oh no and having lost loved ones in my
life just like everyone here and
everyone looking on we want to work
every day to make that number of losses
the lowest possible and it will take all
of us to do it and to keep doing exactly
what we're doing through today dr. Burks
they should go right for resident I just
want to start where the Vice President
left off I come out of the services army
when you we always talk about honoring
the fallen and I think for every
American what we can do now to honor the
fallen that have fallen and given that
really their deaths to this des
stareable disease to the health care
workers that are then front lines trying
to save every single one to honor them
and to honor our elders and the
individuals that we know are at the
greatest risk for bad outcomes we all
need to continue to do our work yes the
number of cases have stabilizing or is
stabilizing but I do want
go through those numbers with you
because we talk about these as micro
epidemics in metro areas and in rural
areas so in the New York metro area
which includes obviously northern New
Jersey Connecticut and Rhode Island
there is still 11,000 new cases per day
and their positivity rate on their
testing is still in the 40% plus range
so there's still a significant amount of
disease there and everyone needs to
continue to follow the guidelines New
Orleans metro area 800 new cases per day
but a serial positivity rate on their
testing of 28 percent Detroit metro area
1,400 cases per day 26 percent
positivity Chicago 1,200 cases per day
and 18 percent Boston 18 percent
positivity 1,100 cases per day Denver
has fallen to 180 cases today per day
but still has 15 percent seropositivity
and they're testing California and
Washington have stayed stable at about
on Seattle 350 cases per day on the LA
metro areas 800 cases per day but their
test positive rates are remaining in the
nine percent range and so this really
gives us some idea of what it takes they
have been continuously mitigating
imagine what we're talking about New
York going from 40-plus percent zero
positivity and 11,000 cases a day down
to the LA metro area of 800 cases per
day and 9 percent so this is what when
the president talks about reaching the
top and coming down those are the kinds
of things we need to see and the only
way we will see them is if every
American continues to follow the
guidance now in the Philadelphia metro
area where I come from it's 1,400 cases
per day this of course includes Camden
the counties around the Philadelphia
Metro and Wilmington and in the
Baltimore and the Washington DC area 15
percent zero positivity and five hundred
cases per day and 200 cases per day and
Baltimore this is how we're looking at
it county by county
Metro by Metro rural region by rural
region to make sure we don't miss
anything and we're triangulating testing
data with the attack rates with a
hospitalization with a number of cases
and really creating a mosaic of who
needs what when to ensure that every
American is served well I had a great
call today with a group of pediatricians
the head of the American Academy of
Pediatrics and with the American College
of obstetrics and gynecology behind the
scenes and working every day are the
pediatricians fielding those phone calls
from every concerned mother and of
course grandmothers like myself and
protecting our children every day to
ensure that they have access to the
medical care that they need while this
is happening and to every pregnant woman
out there I was very reassured hearing
from the American College of obstetrics
and gynecology they have put amazing
things in place to protect every
pregnant woman they have been social
distancing in their offices they have
increased all of the disinfecting they
have lengthened the time between clients
to every pregnant woman don't miss your
appointments if your OB thinks you need
to be there you should go and please
know that on the labor and delivery
wards they are doing everything to
protect you in their babies they are
committed to you
they are absolutely committed to you
having a good experience make sure if
your physician believes you should be in
the hospital for your delivery make sure
you're following their guidance we don't
want any pregnant women to suffer a bad
outcome during this time so again I just
want to conclude by thanking the
American people and recognizing the
number of people were losing per day is
serious to all of us and it could be so
much worse
but our frontline health care providers
and the way they're talking to each
other about how to improve care for
every individual that they serve you see
them on the TV you see them in the
emergency room you see what they're up
against this is how we can honor them is
to make sure we continue
to put as dr. Falchi always says put
your foot on the gas and make sure that
we continue to strongly mitigate and
really protect those with pre-existing
conditions and finally those
pre-existing conditions we know now
include asthma so asthma hypertension
cardiovascular disease diabetes on any
of these conditions renal disease no
matter what age please make sure you're
following the guidelines to protect
those individuals in your household we
know they're more susceptible to a worse
outcome we don't think that any one's
more susceptible to getting infected I
want to make sure that everyone
understands everybody is susceptible to
getting infected this virus is very
transmittable as we well know but we
need to protect those that need our
protection the most so thank you all for
what you're doing to get the message out
to ensure that we continue to protect
each other in this very difficult time
Thank You mr. vice president I just to
follow up and underscore what dr. Burks
has said as I've said many times from
this podium the the spectrum of going
from infection to getting ill to
requiring hospitalization to intensive
care to death and what is the most
striking thing that obviously is so
sobering to us is when we see the number
of deaths we know now for sure that the
mitigation that we have been doing is
having a positive effect but you don't
see it until weeks later
remember this past weekend when we all
of us got up in front of this podium and
mentioned that this was going to be a
really bad week at the same time we were
saying that we would hope we would start
to see a little bit of a change in the
daily hospitalizations intensive care
and intubations and New York is starting
to see that so I say that but I drop
back a bit don't get complacent about
that because what's gonna happen two and
a half weeks from now is really what's
gonna happen with regard to the people
who are getting new infection as dr.
Berg said everybody is almost certainly
as susceptible as anybody else to
getting infected it
what happens to you after you get
infected and and again to just keep
emphasizing we need to keep mitigating
we know that if this is something that
is a strain on the American public but
it's just something that we have not
only the only tool it's the best tool
and to just shift a bit to what we said
yesterday regarding the african-american
community it is very painful to see and
I've seen it throughout my entire
medical career that the health
disparities and the minority community
but particularly the african-american
community puts them at risk
apart from Corona right var virus issues
puts them at risk for diseases much more
so than the general population the
double whammy that you suffer now is
when you have this terrible virus which
essentially preys in its ultimate
deleterious effects on people with those
underlying conditions and since that is
more predominant in the african-american
population we want to double down and
say to the young people to the elderly
people in that community to please try
as best as you can to protect yourself
if you're a younger person and to please
protect the people who are susceptible
your grandmother your grandfather your
elder uncle the people who have these
underlying conditions because we are not
gonna solve the issues of health
disparities this month or next month
this is something we should commit
ourselves four years to do yes but what
we can do now today is to prevent people
who are put at higher risk because of
the demographic group from getting into
a situation which is much much more
deleterious than the general population
so I plead with all of us in the
population but particularly for those of
us our brothers and sisters in the
african-american community because we
know that mitigation does work the
reason we know it works is the question
that was asked about the numbers that
why they came down with the projections
because remember what you do with data
will always out
stripper model you redo your models
depending upon your data and our data is
telling us later that mitigation is
working so again as dr. Berg said keep
your foot on the accelerator because
that's what's gonna get us through this
alright guys that does it for me I've
got to run appreciate everybody for
joining me for the last three hours
we'll be back tomorrow show bonus show
livestream all of that stuff it
continues
you